- I don't know exactly
how the woke people
got in charge here
in so many places.
It's partially 'cause
they're so loud.
I think there's 5 or
10% of people here
who really believe
in that stuff.
And they've gotten very good.
I think it came from
the universities.
You look at our
big tech companies.
The culture at Google is
really modeled off of Stanford
'cause of all the PhDs,
same thing with a lot
of the other ones.
And so these tech companies
are basically taking a culture
from a university that's
been broken for a few decades
and these woke people are
really good at punishing people
who stand up to them
and trying to get them.
And so it's just not worth
people's time to push back.
And so, if you're just
trying to do your job,
you're just doing what you can.
Seeing these people get to be
in charge, it's really bad.
(light music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and this is "The Rubin
Report" Locals Week.
Joining me today is an
entrepreneur and investor
and policy maker at the Cicero
Institute, Joe Lonsdale,
welcome to "The Rubin Report."
- Thanks, Dave. Good to be on.
- Joe I've wanted to have
you on for quite some time,
because you're involved
in about a billion things
that ancillarily are
all about the things
that I talk about on this
show, from tech to politics,
free speech,
education, all of it.
But first let's start
with those two words
that I mentioned up front,
entrepreneur and investor.
I feel like when you
say that to people,
people think, oh, you
were just born that way.
How does somebody become an
entrepreneur and investor?
I suspect a lot of my audience
would like to have
those two tags.
- There's a lot of different
types of this, but for me,
it's about, you see things
and they work a certain way
and you're frustrated
and you want to fix them.
I think having a vision of
how the world should work,
that's not how it's
working right now,
that'll lead one to
being an entrepreneur.
'Cause that's basically
the only way to do things
to evolve the economy.
- So how'd you get started?
For the guy out there
watching this right now,
going, okay, I got a regular
job, but I've got an idea
or I'm passionate
about something,
how did it work for you?
- Well, you know, technology
is a really big part
of what you need to be a
great entrepreneur these days.
You don't have to
be a technologist,
but it's a big advantage
to learn technology,
learn computer science.
I grew up in the Bay
Area. I was very lucky.
I was born in Silicon Valley,
had a bunch of friends who
were great technologists.
They taught me from a young age.
I went to Stanford,
computer science
and met a lot of
great technologists.
When I was there. I saw a
lot of the smartest people
were going to work at PayPal.
At the time it was 2000,
what's this PayPal thing?
There's one company
started by Peter Thiel,
and one company
started by Elon Musk
and they merged and
they made PayPal.
So of course, Peter brought
his smartest friends.
Elon brought his
smartest friends.
And I said, wow, I
want to work there.
And they actually rejected
me the first time,
but I tried again
and they let me in,
and I learned a lot from them.
So I think what you want is
follow the best technologists,
learn technology and
go study other people
who know what they're doing.
And that's probably the
good way to get started.
- So as a guy that was
involved in those magic years
of Silicon Valley and of
big tech and all that,
when you look back on it, does
it feel like a dream sort of,
seeing the way
big tech has moved
and how the
landscape has changed
and how people generally
talk about big tech
versus probably what you were
seeing when it was being born?
Does it all just
feel very weird?
'Cause it's not that
long ago, as you said.
- Yeah. I remember being
at a dinner with Peter.
He was the first investor in
Facebook and Mark was there.
I know the Facebook
founders really well,
of course from this background,
I remember being jealous
because the other really
important people at the table
were treating Mark as
more important than me.
And I said Palantir's going
to be a really big company.
Why do you think Facebook's
necessarily going to be bigger?
So obviously I was wrong
that we were gonna be
nearly as big as Facebook.
I went public last
week for $22 billion.
So we didn't do horribly.
We're not worth five,
whatever Mark's worth
trillion dollars.
It is interesting having known
a lot of these characters.
They're very ardent,
very hardworking people.
I don't think any of us knew
how big these companies
were going to get though.
- I like how you just,
poo-pooed 22 billion.
Yeah, 22 billion last week.
We'll get to that, by the way.
- There's always
someone who's crushed it
and done way better
than you, right?
At least, that's
been my experience.
- It's kind of funny.
I was actually going to get
there a little bit later,
but let's just jump to it.
Do the numbers when you
say something like that,
so Palantir went
to IPO $22 billion,
the numbers start to seem crazy.
Do they seem crazy even to
you guys that are in it?
Because I think to
the average person,
you can't fathom
what $1 billion is.
I don't think most people can
fathom what $10 million is.
- I guess in some ways I'm lucky
that it took so long
because as things take time
over the years, you
kind of adjust to it.
I think if it were to all of
a sudden fall in your lap,
after a couple of years,
it would probably be
extremely unhealthy.
There was things I worked
on with Peter, at the fund
where we had a hedge fund
that kind of blew up one year
where I would've
gotten this giant bonus
as a 25 year old and I
didn't and looking back,
it's probably good
that I didn't.
'Cause if you just get a
bunch of money all at once,
it's hard to adjust to it.
If you build these
things over time,
you kinda learn
how to manage it.
You learn the money is not
like a bunch of gold coins.
If you asked me as a kid,
I would've thought I
was like Scrooge McDuck.
And there's like a tower,
and there's gold coins in it.
That's what money is,
but it's actually-
- You don't dive into your
tower with a big dollar sign?
- Maybe at some point we
should figure that out.
I just had break
Peter Thiel yesterday,
he made more on Palantir of
course, than PayPal is worth.
When it was sold to eBay, of
course, when he first did it,
but these people, the money
represents these missions
and these causes and
the money is ownership
and something you've built.
So it becomes much more
about, the money, sure,
it's worth some large
amount on paper,
but it's much more
about the ability
to get things done in the world,
ability to influence things.
At some point it's not money
you're gonna spend for yourself,
it's money you're gonna use
to achieve stuff
and to build stuff.
- Do you think that's the
fundamental disconnect
when we talk about money
and when there's a certain
level of resentment,
when these companies go to IPO
or when they see people
getting these huge payouts
or something that they
don't really understand
the work that it took,
and the way these
things change industries
and everything else?
There's a disconnect between
what's actually going on
with a lot of these companies
and what the media
portrays it all as.
- Of course it's a
massive amount of work.
And of course, a lot of people
wouldn't take bets on these
things, wouldn't invest in them,
wouldn't do them if
there wasn't an economy
where you could
earn lots of money.
But I think the
biggest disconnect
is that there's
really two options
with these resources
we're creating,
is once the resource
has been created
either you're gonna have
a bunch of committees
and bureaucrats in
charge of that money,
or you're gonna have these
really hardworking people
who know how to build
things in the world
like Elon Musk and Peter Thiel,
and all sorts of other
people with different views,
who've created this money,
using it as they see fit.
It's amazing.
Most of the money in the world
now is running by committees.
Most of the money is
taken by pension funds,
sovereign wealth funds.
Like 98% of the
money in the world
is controlled by
these big, slow,
boring things like
insurance companies.
And those guys don't
usually do anything
that's that interesting.
Whereas there's this
small number of people
who've created wealth
that's like the last
free wealth in the world.
And the people want to take that
and give it to the
committees too.
It's like, what
are you thinking?
Don't you want people
who know how to build
taking this and using
it for something?
- So you're giving me
the perfect segue to,
I think something that a
lot of people wonder about,
how is it that a place
like Silicon Valley
that has so much of the spirit
that you're talking about,
these people who want
to change the world,
who want to invent and
innovate and the rest of it,
how is it that the
social justice thing,
which is so counter
to that in many ways,
how did it infect almost
everything to the point
that everybody's leaving
San Francisco right now?
- Yeah, it's a huge problem
in the culture of
Silicon Valley.
This has been the case,
for a very long time
is when you're very successful
and wealthy and philanthropic,
I think a lot of people will
have some level of guilt
about their success.
And then the guilt, doesn't
have to be rational.
It's just like, you're guilty.
There's people who
are poor in the world
and you have success.
So the cultural
norm, I think becomes
to be very, very careful
about being proud
of your success,
about showing off any
pride, any of that at all.
And the default
becomes taken over by
the left at some point.
I don't know exactly how the
woke people got in charge here
in so many places,
it's partially 'cause
they're so loud.
I think there's 5 or
10% of people here
who really believe
in that stuff.
And they've gotten very good.
I think it came from
the universities.
You look at our
big tech companies,
the culture at Google is really
modeled off of Stanford's.
It's all the PhDs, same thing
with a lot of the other ones.
And so these tech companies
are basically taking a culture
from a university that's been
broken for a few decades.
And these woke people are
really good at punishing people
who stand up to them
and trying to get them.
And so it's just not worth
people's time to push back
and so, if you're just
trying to do your job,
you're just doing what you can.
And these people get to be
in charge. It's really bad.
- So how do you run
companies then, and make sure
that they don't get
infected by these ideas?
- It's really important
who you hire, first of all.
A lot of our companies,
you gotta be really careful
who you let into your company.
You do not want a
social justice activist
who's gonna be
stirring things up.
I loved what the CEO
of Coinbase, Brian
Armstrong put out
the other day that
a lot of us shared.
Our company is not about
all these other things.
It's about our mission.
There's other places you can go,
if you want to focus on other
missions, this is our mission.
So a lot of my companies, we
spend a decent amount of time
just being really
careful who we let in.
And I have to teach
CEOs, this is your job.
Don't come to me a
year from now and say,
this is so horrible, these
people are so distracting.
They're pushing us to do
all these stupid things.
That would have been your fault
for not figuring out,
and for hiring them.
So this is something
a lot of people are
learning about right now.
- It's funny.
I always find it interesting
how it deviates from the
core mission, always.
Every single commercial
you watch these days,
it's a company, but it's
not about their product.
It's about what quote,
unquote, good they're doing.
The only company that I
know, like major company,
that's not doing it is T-Mobile.
All their commercials
are about their product.
And I'm always like, oh, I
know what they're selling,
it's incredible!
- That's a real company.
I think there is a role
for consumer brands
to stand for values
that people believe in.
I think in a free market,
people could choose
to put their money
towards brands
that go towards things
they believe in.
And if it was purely reflecting
the desires of the market,
I think that's interesting.
I think the problem is a
lot of these big companies
is the marketing
departments are conquered
by people with these
extremely warped views
that do not reflect
their customers.
And that becomes a
really weird disconnect
that I'm hoping the market
will solve for that eventually
by pushing back on
some of these things.
- Yeah. All right.
So let's back up to
that poo-pooh moment
when you poo-pooed
the 22 billion.
So Palentir went to IPO,
it's about 10 days ago,
by the time we post this.
I've had Peter on as you know,
but can you just explain
what Palentir is?
I feel like Palentir gets a
lot of really bizarre press
and people have no concept
of what it actually is.
- It's because it is a pretty
complicated thing to explain.
The best way I
like to look at it
is we're taking things that
used to be done by IT services.
So we started off
in the defense world
and the intelligence world.
And the US government
spends $40 billion a
year gathering data.
And then they spend a
similar amount of money
paying IT service professionals
to try to build systems,
to let the analysts
see the data,
let them share it, et cetera.
And it's a mess. Their
projects go way over budget.
They waste billions of dollars
as you'd expect on these things.
They're paying
people to do things
the same way they did
in the 1980s, 1990s.
And so looking at
this after 9/11,
we said, wait a second here.
The technology in Silicon Valley
has gotten way ahead of
everything DC is doing.
That was a sad thing
for us to realize.
Because when you're
a computer scientist,
you look at the NSA in the 1970s
and they were way ahead
of everyone else by far.
So it used to be the US
government was way ahead.
It's not anymore, no question.
And so we said, how
can we build a platform
that out of the box
replaced the need
for the tens of
billions of spend?
So our platforms is an
information environment,
where you could take in
data from tons of places,
to process it, it's very,
very expensive and hard to do
and takes a very long
time, and then secure it
and make sure only people who
are allowed to can see it.
And then allow
people to build tools
on top of it to collaborate.
So for example, we help
intelligence agencies
around the world collaborate.
We help aerospace companies
and their suppliers
collaborate with data.
So it basically helps
you use all the data
you're allowed to use
and only people who are supposed
to see things, see them.
It's a hard IT problem.
- So for more libertarian
minded guys, like you and Peter,
does that cause a little
bit of an ethical dilemma?
You're working with
the government!
- Well there's two
different things there.
First of all, what was happening
before we built Palantir,
was they were building
systems to see things
with basically very
little safeguards.
Imagined Jack Bauer
in the show "24,"
and there's a terrorist.
He'd just going to
go in the database
and take the fricking
data he needs
because otherwise someone's
going to die, right?
A lot of people were like,
screw civil liberties.
We're just gonna
take whatever we can.
And so as civil
libertarians, we said, no,
we're going to build Palantir.
It's going to give them
more powerful access,
but it's also going to be
able to make audit trails.
We're gonna know
exactly who did what,
and we're going to
enforce the rules.
And whatever the rules are,
we're going to enforce them.
We don't make the rules.
President Obama makes the rules,
President Bush made rules.
We were going to
enforce whatever the
rule, Congress does,
we're gonna reinforce
those rules.
Actually, Palantir is like the
most awesome privacy engine
in the world because
we've really enforced it.
If you use Palantir,
it's very hard for you
to get away with anything
you're not supposed to do.
That was something we
were really heartened by.
The second one's an
interesting question.
I built a lot of
things now in gov tech.
I think for me, it's
part of being a realist.
You asked about
being a libertarian,
Cato is the most
famous libertarian in
the Roman Republic.
And what Cato would would do
is he wouldn't
compromise at all.
So he's really admired
for being uncompromising
and constantly fighting
for what was right.
But because he
wouldn't compromise,
he wouldn't work with Pompei.
Pompei went over to Caesar.
They eventually
lost the Republic
because he was so stubborn.
He couldn't get things done
and therefore you
lost the entire thing.
And the entire thing was gone.
So as much as I admire Cato,
and I have a lot of Cato in me
as I've grown up, I'm a realist.
And so I want to fight for my
values as well as possible.
But if the government's
gonna be doing something,
let's actually help it reflect
our values of a free society,
as much as possible.
Let's helping not
waste billions,
let's help it protect
civil liberties.
Let's help it actually
get the terrorists,
because the worst of all
worlds is that the government
is doing all these things and
it's viciously incompetent.
I think that's probably
really bad for everyone.
- Yeah, you're
speaking my language.
So can you explain
to me then as someone
that has worked with
the US government,
why are there so many
government websites
that are so ridiculously
old and broken?
I always use the example,
and you as a California guy,
I pay my California
State taxes on a website
that literally looks like
it's Prodigy from 1999.
Why is that?
- Dave, there's
no accountability.
And there's no incentives.
And the people who win
these government contracts
are working through these really
byzantine procurement rules
that favor the incumbents,
and favor of the people
that have paid for massive
amounts of lobbying.
They've been doing it
the same way since 1987,
or whenever they started
building these things,
probably '97 for that
website, you know?
So what we need in government
is we need to completely
change our procurement works
and we need to have
accountability and how metrics
and all the same things
you do in a business.
In my businesses, if
we have a website,
there's certain rules for
measuring how well it's doing
and measuring the feedback
and NPS scores, right?
An NPS score is when you
get how much people like it
and how much they
recommend it to friends.
There's things like this, the
government should have to do.
The biggest problem
is government has special
interests everywhere.
Especially government unions
that refuse to let them
be held accountable.
So until we can hold our
governments accountable,
it's gonna keep being broken.
- Yeah. All right.
I want to shift a little
bit because as you know,
we're doing Locals Week here.
When I created Locals and
when I had the idea of Locals
and I brought in some
of the team for Locals,
we had to raise a
little bit of dough,
and I started asking around,
your name just kept popping up.
People just kept saying, this
sounds like Joe Lonsdale,
you gotta talk to Joe Lonsdale.
I'm not even totally sure
how we got connected.
We jumped on a
Zoom or on a Skype.
And in the first conversation
within five minutes,
you were like, yeah,
I want to throw you guys
some money and good luck.
And you've helped guide
us with this thing.
When someone approaches you,
this doesn't have to be
about Local specifically,
but generally when
people approach you
with ideas like this, what
goes through the checklist
in your mind of like, oh, this
is something I want to fund,
or I see something here,
or I'm gonna write a
massive check for this one
or a little bit for this one.
What is the whole process like?
- Sure. 8VC is my venture fund.
We run a multi-billion
dollar venture capital firm.
There's 40 people, 9 partners.
And at 8VC, we have different
themes we're focused on.
And the big question there
is what's possible now
that was not possible
five years ago?
That's the big question.
And we look for really
taught technology cultures
and tech talent and help
nurture and build those.
Then we look for them
working on these problems
that are newly
possible, because again,
the job of venture capital
is to evolve the economy.
So you have a lot of
things in that vein.
I also do a much smaller
amount of personal investing
when something is just
really important to me,
ideologically, or for the world,
even if it doesn't fit
exactly into my VC bucket.
I love to support things
I think are very important
for the world, like
what you guys are doing.
- Yeah.
Do you sense that
the small internet
or the bottom up
internet is the future?
That we're gonna move away
from these big tech platforms
and do things a little bit more
like what we're
doing with Locals,
where people will create
their own communities
and figure out how to network up
so it's really just flipping
the whole thing upside down?
- I would love that
to be the case.
I think in some cases
that will be what happens.
One of the big challenges
that's unusual right now
is in the old days, when
you think of a monopoly,
you think of something that
gets to be somewhat decadent
and starts to decline.
And right now there
is, at least for today,
an advantage that the
big companies have,
is they keep attracting the
very, very, very top talent.
So as much as I think
they're doing things
that are morally and ethically
wrong, a big challenge,
we're gonna face to bring
that vision you mentioned,
which is possibly a good vision
is how do we compete
for top talent?
Because it's a very
unusual circumstance.
They may be monopolies,
but they are just hiring
all the top talent,
which is very impressive
to still watch.
- Yeah. And it's like,
you you've got some dough.
It's not like you can't compete,
but they've got,
even more dough!
- They have this money machine.
People think Palantir being
worth $22 billion is something.
Google has a money
machine, I think shoots off
like three or four billion
of free cash flow a quarter.
It's just ridiculous how
much money these guys have.
- Do you know what they're
actually making money on
at this point?
I've heard a bunch of
people talk about this,
that it's like, what
products do they have
that are actually making money?
- One of my companies
actually funds a few
percent of their revenue
for Google and Facebook.
It's the number two
to Amazon called Wish.
And we just advertise.
And we do like Dollar
Store stuff online
it's like having
a Walmart online.
So there's things like that
where we're selling
stuff to consumers
and consumers are finding it.
But there's basically
everything you sell,
these guys make money
on, especially Google.
Anything you might search for,
anything you might
want to figure out
Google's gotten to be very,
very good at monetizing.
- Yeah.
What do you think generally
about the subscription
versus ad model these days?
Is that changing
a little bit now
that that people have woken
up to some of this stuff?
- Yeah, I think that you said,
I think for the bottom up world,
you're gonna start
seeing a lot more
of a subscription model
and how things work.
I think that is how
media should work.
My favorite media,
I'm a subscriber to
whether it's like,
the information
is slightly woke, but it's
better than the other ones.
It's hard to find
everything you get.
I think a lot of stuff
you guys feature is,
there's a lot of people on there
who definitely we're
following and subscribing to.
I think things are shifting
back to subscription
because it's a healthier
thing, but we're gonna see,
it hopefully get more
in that direction.
- Yeah.
So let's talk a little bit
about your your political life.
So first off, for people that
have no idea what Cicero is,
can you just explain
what they are first
then we'll talk about your
involvement a little bit.
- Yeah, sure.
It kind of grew out of a
lot of my other activity
where you you'd learn
about different industries
and you'd say, wow,
this is really broken.
I wonder why this
part of healthcare
doesn't work this
much better way
that would be like five
times as efficient?
And sometimes you'll find
out, well, they need a system.
We need to do something
as an entrepreneur
and we'll build companies.
But a lot of times you'll say,
it's not because no
ones built a company,
it's because the
policy is just wrong.
It's like the policy here
is causing healthcare to be
three times as expensive.
The policy here
is causing housing
to be twice as expensive as
it should be in this area.
And so the more I
look at politics
and the more I get
afraid of socialists,
coming and convincing our
kids to be socialists,
the more I've realized, wow,
every area of our
society that's broken,
it tends to be broken
because of big government.
And because the best ideas
are not allowed to
compete and win.
What you want in society,
the reason free society works
is if someone has a better idea,
that idea wins out over time.
This is a better way for us
to do probation and parole
because less people
will go back to jail.
You want a way for
that idea to win.
And I think a lot of people
don't understand this.
They think that you
could just publish,
this is a better
way to run a prison.
And then other people
will just adopt it.
And then society
will move forward.
And it turns out that's
not how society works.
That's a false model of society.
The correct model of society
is you have to have a
competition of ideas.
You have to have accountability.
You have to have something
that makes the bad ideas lose
and the good ideas win.
And so Cicero is helping
put forward laws.
It's helping figure out where
we can take these best ideas
and identify them
and create systems
where the best ideas
will win in these areas.
- Is the hardest part of
that just the messaging?
Where I think most
people, unfortunately,
they just see, oh,
something's screwed up.
It just needs more money.
That's just like the
one level thought.
- I think it's a really
hard thing to teach people
to think in terms of systems,
most people are not
systems thinkers.
A good leader might say,
this is a good program.
I'm going to give it money.
Whereas a great
leader would say,
how do we redesign the system
so that the good
things are winning
and the bad things
are going away?
The redesign the system problem
is not what people think.
The market is a system.
The market's one of the
greatest systems there is.
And the more we can reflect
the better systems, the better.
But you're right, people
don't understand it very well.
- Right, can you give
me a couple examples
of the type of things,
let's talk about healthcare.
What can we do to clear
up this healthcare mess?
Give me your presidential
debate platform.
- There's so many
things we're pushing.
There's a group called PBMs.
Three of the Fortune
20 companies are PBMs,
pharmacy benefit manufacturers.
They're the guys
who tell pharmacists
what drugs they could sell and
make them available to them.
They're kind of the middlemen
on drugs in America.
And they do all these things
where they gag everyone.
And so one thing we stopped
them from doing, which was good.
we finally passed it in
the Senate two years ago,
I was very, very involved
putting this forward
is they used to say,
okay, pharmacists,
if there's two
generic drug options,
even if one is, 20 times
cheaper than the other,
if the doctor prescribes
the more expensive one,
you're not allowed to
tell him or the patient,
you can't tell her or the
patient about the cheaper ones.
Totally crazy, right?
So we got rid of that.
That's illegal now.
- What was the
logic behind that?
That's just purely because
they're in the pocket
of big pharma?
- It's just their cartel.
It's their cartel power.
They like being able
to make tons more money
using their cartel.
- Yeah.
- They say we're not gonna
give you these other drugs
only we have access to
because we're this cartel
and it's really hard
regulatorily to compete with us
unless you don't
tell these things.
But here's another
thing they do.
They don't let people tell
the prices they're paying.
So pharmacists would
love to be able to say,
hey, other PBM, upstart, here's
what I'm paying on these.
Can you give me a better
deal? And that's illegal.
You're not allowed to.
Prices are trade secret,
according to these
cartels in America.
And there's lots of parts
of healthcare like this,
where all the prices
are trade secrets,
and they won't tell
you ahead of time
because that stops competition
from coming in on them.
Insurance companies would
love to be able to go
to other providers and say,
these people are charging us
this much over here.
Can we pay a lot less?
There's all these gag orders
where you can't do that,
it's against the rules.
In my view, in order for
free market to work better,
you want competition.
And therefore you want
to ban these gag orders.
Gag orders are something
only cartels would want.
It's amazing, Dave,
you go to Congress and talk
to senators and they say,
I've had all these people
visit me from the pharma lobby.
And they've explained to me
that if this thing
was transparent,
everyone would collude
and prices will go up.
I was like, okay guys, they're
paying billions of dollars
to convince you of this, right?
That if it was transparent,
it would make the markets
not functioning as well.
This is the senators
on both sides, man.
I love working on issues, and
obviously believe in freedom
and believe in free markets.
But there are people
bought off in this country
on both sides by these lobbyists
who are not putting in
the pro-market solutions.
And so we're working hard on it.
I'm optimistic we're gonna win.
But in every one of these areas,
there's just stuff like this
that just drives me crazy.
- It's kinda hilarious.
You go into a
congressman's office.
They tell you that if they
take the secrecy away,
and then everyone can actually
negotiate, prices will go up.
They definitely missed
something in economics 101.
- I've literally had
conversations like this
with people on both parties.
And there are people
in both parties
who are on the
good guy side too.
It drives me crazy.
- Do you find the
partisan gridlock?
Is it 50/50? is one side
worse than the other?
I think generally speaking,
people on the right
are a little more open
to free market stuff,
but is it pretty close?
- People in their right are
more open to free market stuff.
But the Freedom
Caucus, for example,
while I admire a lot of them,
a lot of them are Cato's
where the thing
that I said earlier,
where they're so extreme,
that they won't even
compromise a little bit.
It's interesting in
the Bush White House,
I have a lot of
admiration for Dick Cheney
on a lot of issues.
But Dick Cheney was so stubborn
as a Cato on this issue
that he didn't want to
require transparency.
'Cause he said the market
should be able to figure it out.
We shouldn't have to
require transparency.
But all these other
healthcare analysts,
including myself say,
it's pretty obvious
that you do need
transparency here
'cause that's the only
way it's gonna work.
And there's so many little
mini monopolies and whatnot,
it makes them more
like a market,
more like a free society
with more competition.
And he was afraid to
impose transparency
because he thought that was
telling the market what to do.
So it's interesting.
You have people on the far right
who are pretty intransigent
sometimes about some
of these things.
- Yeah.
What else should
we be thinking of
as the big issues
related to healthcare?
Like, okay, prescription
drug prices,
what are the other types
of things that you work on?
- The other really big one,
so what you look
for, in these spaces,
you look for where all the
contribution margin is,
what contribution
margin is in businesses,
you know what it is, of course.
It's how much money
businesses are actually making
on the services
they're providing.
And the biggest area
of contribution margin
is health providers.
Health providers are
hospitals basically,
or things like hospitals.
It's really egregious
how this works.
And it's tough
'cause no one wants to be
against their local hospital.
It sounds like the thing
you should give money to
and support, but a
lot of hospitals,
Medicare and Medicaid literally
will pay two to
three times as much
for the exact same service
to a hospital versus a clinic
because the hospitals
have so much power
and they've set
things up that way.
And they say, oh, we
have to get paid more
because have more expenses.
And I'm thinking, wait
a second, in a market,
you don't want to have to
pay three times as much,
for the same exact outcome,
or even a worse outcome.
It's really interesting
if you map it out,
there's all these health systems
that have bought up lots
of things in an area
to give themselves
more pricing power,
because if they
buy the one nearby,
then you can't have competition.
You can't actually have an
insurance company that says,
well, we're only going to
work with this reasonable one,
not this other one.
And it's really bad.
And here's the thing
that's really crazy.
A lot of these health
systems are nonprofits.
And so if you say,
oh, it's a nonprofit,
that means it must be a
good guy for the world.
You can't do anything.
And so the FTC, the
Federal Trade Commission
is not allowed to look
at nonprofits right now.
So you have all these
things have gone nonprofit,
have bought up massive
amounts of an area,
and then can jack up
the prices and a lot.
And the people
running the nonprofit
are making huge
amounts of money,
even though it's
officially a non-profit,
and it's a big problem.
One of the big
things is antitrust
and letting the FTC do antitrust
against nonprofits as well.
And really what it's about
is it's about
creating competition.
It's about putting markets
back into place here.
- Yeah.
How do you decide
when the government
can get involved there, the
libertarian side of you?
Well, I guess that's
what you're saying
about being a realist
as opposed to a purist.
- You have to be a realist.
And the libertarian thing here
is make it easier to
start competitors, right?
Make it easier to start
health clinics to compete.
The problem is if you
have a monopoly power
that's just so
dominant in that area.
And you're allowed to
tell the health insurance,
if you work with this guy,
we won't work with you
and everything's secret,
and you can't say
what we're charging you.
They basically become these
things that kill competition.
And that's fundamentally,
un-American.
America works better if you
have competition in these areas.
And there's lots of ways.
There's lots of
good academic work
on measuring what a
monopoly is or not.
It's comical to me
that we're going after
the tech monopolies
to start right now,
when we have a much bigger
problem in this country
of the healthcare law plays
on all sorts of local levels.
And if the FTC should use
the academic literature,
that's been written by both
sides the last 70 years,
the conservative
view of antitrust, in
my view is correct.
The Borkean view, basically
that Bork created,
as one of the great
legal scholars,
which is you look at the impact
on consumer and the prices.
And you can very
clearly see places
where we're spending two, three,
four times as much
for certain services.
It's very clearly a monopoly.
If there's any view where the
FTC's supposed to do something
to me, that should be it.
And again, if you want to say
that you don't need
government at all, sure.
If you got rid of all
healthcare regulations,
and made it really
easy to compete,
maybe this problem
would solve itself,
but we're not gonna get
rid of all those things.
And so therefore
let's find some way
to get competition
and make it healthy.
- So what would the
right system look like?
Would it be just a lot
of individual companies
that are sort of corralled
by the government
to have to play fairly?
What does it actually look like?
- You want it to be as
open as possible, right?
You want to be as
open as possible.
You want new types
of competition to
be able to come in.
You want people to be able to
choose their own health plans.
One of the things government
messed up, as you know,
is in the 1940s in World War II,
we made it so you
couldn't pay people more,
but you could give
them benefits.
And we made healthcare
a tax-free benefit.
So it created the
system in our country
where we started
expecting to get things,
of course, people want
to pay people more,
so they just gave them better
and better health plans.
And so everyone that used
to having a health plan
from their company tax-free,
and not choosing it themselves.
And so it got rid of
a lot of choice there.
And people don't even know.
Some random HR person
who's probably super woke
is the one choosing your
healthcare plan for you for.
For a lot of Americans,
that's not how
things should work.
And so what it should be,
it should be that people
choose their own health plan.
Avik Roy has something,
Senator Braun, I think,
put out yesterday, which was a
really great new health plan.
And what it is is basically,
it's going to cover everyone.
It's not gonna cover rich
people, it's means tested.
So anyone 55 or under, you're
not going to get Medicare,
if you're rich going forward.
And it's gonna cover
everyone using the market,
which is that everyone
gets to choose
their own private insurance
company and any new startups,
the people have to choose the
health insurance themselves.
And then in the meantime
we're gonna have antitrust,
we're gonna have transparency,
and we're gonna push back on
these really sketchy tactics
people use on IP, on drugs,
where they've had
the IP for decades,
and they're still
keeping it expensive.
It's a combination
of using markets,
using private insurance
and means testing.
This is a compromise again,
and covering everyone.
But basically
everything's private,
but the bottom gets
covered by the government.
And that combination
would save money and work.
I think we need a
compromise like this
to keep our health system free.
- Yeah, have you been tracking
what Jared Kushner
is doing with Oscar?
Is that related to any of the
types of things you're doing?
- That's Jared's brother Josh.
- Sorry. Josh, yeah.
- He's a good friend of mine
Josh Kushner, Jared is very busy
making peace in the Middle East.
- (laughing) Jared's got
other things going on.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Josh, Josh.
- I am a fan of the
Kushner brothers.
A lot of my friends
in the Valley say, oh,
that Jared guy must be horrible.
I show him some stuff he's
doing or connect them to him.
And they end up
liking him in person.
He's actually a pretty
smart guy, in my opinion.
Josh has done a
great job with Oscar.
There's a lot of
ways Oscar uses data
and uses telemedicine,
no one had done before.
It was fascinating.
We had a bunch of clinics
on the platform of course.
This is a health insurance
company that's growing quickly.
I've put a $100 million into it,
it's one of my 20 or
30 big investments.
And there was like this
pediatrician group.
And they said, how come
we're not on your platform?
And we told him, well, listen,
you guys spend three
times as much on tests
as any of the other
pediatricians in this area.
And they said, oh, wow.
We didn't know that.
No one had ever
told us that before.
And we said, wow,
what a strange space.
These people have no idea how
much money they're spending.
It's such a broken area
that none of the other
insurance companies
had even told them that,
that they were doing
things unnecessarily.
Oscar's done a lot to push
health insurance to use data
and to be a better force,
so I'm very bullish on it.
- Yeah.
I know one of your other
main places of interest
is criminal justice reform.
I feel like this is one
where almost everyone agrees,
something should be done
and there can be something
that's bipartisan.
And in many ways, Trump seems
to be trying to do things
that I thought lefties were
fighting for, for a long time.
How can we fix this
clearly broken system?
- Trump and Jared have
done a good job on this.
There's a lot of
people on the right
who are suspicious
of some of this.
I don't blame them, a lot
of criminal justice reform
is being pitched, like
getting rid of the bail,
or, you make it so you arrest
these guys, they get out
and you have to arrest them
again and then get out.
You have to arrest them again.
There's a lot of ridiculous
criminal justice reform.
I'm not for any of that.
The part that I
am for, is again,
how can you fix the systems
that are failing people?
So, a few systems that
are failing people,
one of them is
probation and parole.
There's literally amazing
probation, parole officers
who really spend time
deploying the tactics
to lower recidivism,
to help these people.
They see their job as
they're serving these people
and they want to keep
them out of prison
and they want to help
them succeed in life.
And they want to
be easy on them,
easy on when they
can't hard on them
when it's helpful for them.
And there's other
probation, parole officers
who are absolutely horrible,
and they're nasty
to these people
and they get a job
but it's too far away
and they don't have time
to see the parole officers.
They throw him back in prison,
Whatever it is,
they're just like,
make things so tough on them.
And so the question is,
how can you have incentives
from probation or parole?
I'm not usually a
fan of California.
We were talking
about this earlier.
I know you're still
staying there in the state.
But one thing they did
really well, 11 years ago
is a bipartisan bill where
they changed the incentives
for county probation offices.
They actually get to
keep some of the money
if they didn't send as
many people back to prison,
as long as the crime
rate didn't go up
and it worked extremely well,
saved the state a billion
dollars over the last 11 years.
And Montana, did
something similar.
So we're taking those successes
and we're teaching people,
okay, let's do this for
California parole now too.
Let's actually have incentives
for the parole officers
actually care about
doing their jobs,
because what happened as
soon as you pass that law,
is all these offices started
studying and sharing notes,
what works to low recidivism?
How do we do this? How
do we care about this?
Suddenly everyone's
getting measured.
Bob you've sent
everyone back to prison
the last seven years, that's
really hurting our numbers.
Maybe you should care about,
not just sending him back.
Maybe you should try,
actually work with them
and try to help them.
And here's some tactics
and techniques we
found work, you know?
And so it's amazing having
accountability in these areas,
what that could do.
- Yeah. What about education?
What's going on here?
It seems to me, choice,
choice, choice, choice, choice.
And yet that seems to be
a scary thing to people.
- Yeah. Well, I'm generally
obviously a fan of choice.
That's the thing we're
talking about in every area
is competition and choice.
But there's different
levels of education.
All of them are
really important.
We've gotta get these
kids when they're young
and make sure they're
not programmed
by Marxists as little
kids, that's important.
But in terms of the
incentives, we can work on.
Incentives are easier to do at
the latter part of education,
because you can
measure the results.
And one of my favorite programs
to really go after right now,
there's something
called Pell Grants.
The Pell Grants were
created for good reason.
It's really, well-meaning,
they're trying to help people
from bad socioeconomic
backgrounds
or lower socioeconomic
backgrounds succeed in life
and send them to college.
And the problem is, is there's
no accountability at all.
So we spend $30 billion a year
on Pell Grants in this country,
and the results are just
completely different.
There's some schools
that do a great job.
And for the exact
same type of kids,
they'll have kept
twice the salary
coming out of those
schools as others.
When you think about university
is not just about
getting a high salary,
I think we can
all agree on that.
University is about
being a great citizen,
to live in a free republic.
It is about moral action.
Those are both legit things
for universities to care about.
But the third thing
definitely is,
learning how to get
skills, to get a job,
learning how to actually
succeed in life.
And if we're going to
spend $30 billion a year,
maybe part of the
Pell Grant program
should care that they're
getting skills or not
when they're going
to these schools.
And because the results
are literally two to one,
the question's, okay, these
really, really crappy schools,
where they probably
all become protestors,
or God knows what they're
gonna do afterwards,
'cause they're going
to have any jobs.
And the average salary is
21,000 or whatever from them,
maybe we shouldn't be
giving as many Pell grants
to go to those schools.
And these great ones
where people are making
more than twice as much as that
maybe they should be
getting more Pell Grants.
The question is how
do you put incentives
into these programs to take
into account of the data?
Right now we don't
do that at all.
And our government
probably should.
- Yeah. Do you think
we could just let
a whole bunch of these
public schools just fail?
That would just
clear out the brush.
- If you do this for Title
IV, too, that would count.
Title IV is the
loans we give out
$100 billion of loans
we give out every year.
And it's pretty obvious
that Pell Grants
plus Title IV are propping
up this bottom 30%
of these schools that are
just absolutely horrid.
And these schools
probably care a lot more
about whatever crazy ethnic
studies things they're doing,
whatever racism they're
teaching our kids
than they actually care about
anything helpful for America.
So yes, Japan did this recently,
they closed a bunch
of their weaker,
wackier liberal arts departments
in their bottom schools.
And it was a big outcry,
but I thought it
was pretty awesome.
The Japanese just did it.
Yeah. Yeah. I think
we can do that too.
Now that of course
would be more something
the right would do, and the
left would scream bloody murder.
So rather than do that,
let's just start
with some incentives
where we maybe trim the bottom
with incentives that
are nonpartisan.
My hope is there's a
non-partisan solution
here that we can
push forward first.
- So, even if you could
do some of that stuff
and you change what
you're doing with grants
and some of the handouts and
some of that kind of stuff,
do you think that the
academic layer of it
has just been so corroded
and calcified and corrupted
that it almost won't
matter whether they pull
some of the string purses
and that kind of thing?
- I think people will
respond to money.
There's gonna be
some academics there
that are going to be
wacky and useless anyway,
but there's gonna be
some of these boards
that react and say, oh, wow.
Rather than talking our
entire board meeting
about how woke we are
and how to be more woke,
maybe we should
look at this data
that says we're not
teaching any useful skills.
And maybe we should see what
these five schools nearby
that're doing
great, are teaching.
Maybe we should add some of
those in, for these poor kids
that are coming here
and try to build a life
rather than just
brainwashing them.
And you're right,
not every one of them
is going to say that.
A lot of them
are just gonna be
completely dysfunctional.
That's why markets are
such an important thing.
Markets get rid of
bad ideas, right?
So if these things
are not working,
then the school
is going to shrink
because there's gonna be some
accountability, you know?
I think some can adapt
and I think some
probably should go away.
- So as a pretty
forward-thinking guy
in a forward-thinking industry,
linking this back to
the political thing,
I think a lot of
people feel like
we're sort of at the
end of something.
My feeling right now with
our political gridlock
is just, we're just at
the end of this thing,
the fact that whether you like
either one of them or not,
that a 77 year old is running
against a 74 year old,
one of them's been in
politics for 47 years.
One of them's been in
private industry, forever.
Good, bad, indifferent,
it doesn't matter.
We're just at the
end of this cycle.
What do you think we need from
our politicians after this?
Well, first off, do you
think there is an after this?
Do you think we get
out of this thing
or does it reconstitute itself
in some other evil form
four years from now?
- You know, it seems very likely
that we potentially get,
if we get some kind
of Biden victory,
the whole thing goes
on a little bit longer.
What we need, is we
need competent outsiders
breaking into government
and shaking it up.
We need people who
understand systems.
What that really means
is you need some non woke
computer scientists, frankly.
You need some engineers
who know how to run things.
And that's something as much
as I'm disgusted by the CCP,
and by things China
does, one huge advantage
China has in certain areas,
is that the majority
of the people
in charge there have
engineering backgrounds.
Majority people in
charge of our country
right now are lawyers.
And I'm not sure that's the
right answer for the future.
We need people who
are optimistic,
who can paint a vision
of how this country
can be much better.
This is what drives
me crazy, Dave,
is it's obvious we
have enough ability
to generate wealth and
prosperity for everyone.
We have a golden age basically.
We have diseases being cured.
Your friend Jennifer won
the Nobel Prize this morning
for CRISPR, right?
There's just amazing stuff
going on in this country
and amazing potential.
And we need people who
could take the optimism,
take the values
of a free society
and show positive sum ways
of solving our problems.
And I think we can get that,
but it's gonna be a
different set of leaders
than we have right now.
- Lonsdale. That's a pretty
solid closing statement.
Although, wait a minute.
I feel like I have to
ask you one more now.
You know with Locals,
we haven't even gone
into series A yet,
but when I get
this thing to IPO,
what kind of party do I
throw at the 22 billion?
What do you do? What
do you do that night?
- (laughing) It's funny, I
had about 30 friends over
who built it with me, but when
of the 50 people I invited
20 of them had already
moved out of California.
So that's why I got
to leave next week.
It's a good success.
Palantir was never as much,
and this is honestly the case,
never was much about the money.
We helped them target and
eliminate over 8,000 bad guys,
including the most famous
ones, in the last decade.
We've helped serve our country.
And we've helped save
a huge amount of money.
So I'm really proud
of the company.
- Awesome, well, Joe Lonsdale,
I enjoyed talking to you
and I'm enjoying working
with you, and I'm gonna see
if I can add a couple more
zeroes to your situation.
- Good luck to you for sure.
- Let me see
what I can do over here.
(laughing)
- I'm bullish on
you, thanks Dave.
- Thanks Joe.
- OK.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful
conversations about tech,
instead of nonstop yelling,
checkout our tech playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full
episode playlists.
They're right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.